قال اعلام مجلس السياده السودانيه ان رئيس
المجلس القائد العام للجيش عبد الفتاح
البرهان ابلغ رئيس الاتحاد الافريقي غزالي
عثمان ان فشل جميع الهدى السابقه يعود
سببه الى عدم وجود اليات فعاله وملزمه
لمتابعه خروقات ميليشيا الدعم السريع
المتمرده واشار الى عدم التزام ميليشيا
الدعم السريع باخلاء منازل المواطنين
والمستشفيات والمرافق العامه والمقر
الحكوميه واكد البرهان لرئيس الاتحاد
الافريقي في اتصال هاتفيا ان الحكومه مع
اي حل ينهي حرب الميليشيا المتمرده
بمساعده المرتزقه الاجانب ويعيد الطمانينه
للشعب السوداني بدوره شدد رئيس الاتحاد
الافريقي رئيس جزر القمر غزالي عثماني على
ضروره ان يكون الحل افريقيا لاحلام السلام
في السودان
قالت نائبه الممثل الاممي في السودان
كليماتين سلامه انها قدمت اوراق اعتمادها
للخارجيه السودانيه واضافت سلامه في
تغريده على حسابها في تويتر انها تتطلع
للتعاون مع المؤسسات الحكوميه لتخفيف
معاناه الشعب السوداني